can't get her stick it up guys this is
Dara from the ham shake video just
finished watching our boy thug nasty
absolutely lay it down tonight I was
laying those spider monkey hitters left
in her right was hyping up to my boys
all day saying he's gonna show up but he
did much respect to him if I got that
English name you guys
UFC with or without the crowd pretty
interesting to hear our guy Joe Rogan
and each can't talk to the fighters but
also pretty awkward when nobody's
clapping when somebody wins so let me
know you guys think Brendan I'm sure you
got something to say should put your
chime in there kind of want to hear you
too Nick chin
what's up game gang buzz buzz huge fan
guys let's buzz young win you watched
him yeah everyone watch them little
brows you watch UFC yeah uh definitely
prefer the crowd
I like the crowd like the energy of the
crowd you know yeah shitty judge them
with a crowd or without a crowd yeah
need a crowd man need a crown the crown
well I mean you've been out there like
what do you think we've also fought with
no crowd on the Ultimate Fighter there's
no crowd oh wow I'll throw the fighters
like six people in the arena and so yeah
what is the would how does it mean for
the fighters it depends a guy like
Cerrone or some of these other guys who
the pressure might get to him no crowd
they perform better I guess uh I thought
Cerrone won that fight yeah I thought he
won that fight yeah he did well yeah but
you know do you don't you want a crowd
man yeah crowd you want the energy yeah
it was awkward I thought it just as a
viewer you know I don't have you know
your introspection into it but the
viewer just as a viewer person I thought
that it was weird we could hear the
corners and what they were talking about
and like it would like that but but or
if you're sitting there and all and you
can hear like like an advantage
oh really it's an advantage huh cuz you
can hear I'm helping you out you can
hear you can hear your corner clear but
you can also hear their corner you can
hear everything they're saying and then
some fighters would pick up what DC was
saying whose brilliant yeah and they
started using his techniques Wow like
Greg Hardy is like he should be kicking
more that legs there and they started
kicking more they
there's advance not having a crowd but
as from a spectator view you want a
crowd yeah would you guys think
I thought everyone fought their best you
don't want to do busy watching old
Nirvana videos think about it oh yeah I
think from a spectator point of view
like it just felt kind of awkward to me
just because I was like I thought it was
like flat the first time I heard it I
thought someone edited like the audio
out and it was like one of those deep
fake videos then I was like oh this is
just how it is
yeah yeah slapping and then they had
Brogan DC an anaconda ends of the
Octagon
so then you don't have the vibe of all
them together feeding off each other oh
really yeah so they're far away so they
were still good they're the bat they're
the best in the sport but you don't have
that that energy right max for just
showing you you're like over there
that's suck that's like Bob and Tom they
have a famous show in the Midwest called
Bob and Tom or they used to and in the
beginning the guys were like right next
to each other and then over the years
they didn't get along and they were
literally like 25 feet from each other
in the same show prior suck I can't
remember what would I turn into her
might still be going on but they just
weren't sit they were not they were like
across the room from each other I
remember when I went in they were across
and that is Bob also super mario only
one of them died I think Bob or Tom so I
think put r.i.p bobber Tom all right
[Laughter]
he looks just like Super Mario anyway
anyway yeah definitely need a crowd out
for sports well yeah
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]